you see ready to fight that's it change
[Music]
different I going here
I do bridge it it I do bring you in but
I don't bring you up so Center my role
is to do
[Music]
it's gonna make you proud
if your head went down I should keep it
going down don't give them back the
balance you know this is terrible so
your head goes down okay sorry the same
thing as they come around sentiments
going forward it's not going down you're
going down so knock down here nor I got
change the first time went down we go
this way so Center for cancer keeps
everything locked so that what I'm
training in is maintaining structure
against this centripetal and difficult
changing horses just like a cowbell
sweetie and you maintain your position
it's the contrast of the wait sweetie
we're normally employees
when you holding posture you condition
in the end they've been trained that way
and train that I'm training that way
right now
I don't let her put my arm whoa I don't
let her make my face or James it I keep
it locked
I doubt about from her heart though she
feels she feel like it's hard but it's
because the Kazushi okay you can't just
more an application of this technique
there's time so it sounds good
it's not as good
all right
so I don't have that tension in my arm
what is heavy right now I know need to
do by this need a message
[Music]
[Applause]
so you you can ignore them you can
ignore the hem and you can ignore that's
just a noble astray okay so I mean
you might he might put his hand up on
the other one you see it doesn't matter
on the table so your it's kind of like
yesterday's thing when you have the help
of chef Tyson oh right right this is
wrong
like you just need the positioning
canister
[Music]
you guys he's here then in the Chinese
you had the multiple dimensions
different no okay that's not even like
gets it up
captain we can rewind change change
okay so there's kind of like an opening
like that right and then person comes in
I guess you could do that but you gonna
have to be fast right because you're
basically you're trying to play Mario
game where you gotta jump on the
platform uh that's there it's going to
close by the way so you need to know
that skill how to take advantage of
openings but it's a low percentage skill
especially when weapons are involved or
you're better than me okay so don't get
confuse them like I'm here and I go into
that opening right what I what I'm
trying to do is we're going to here
well that's it I run forward give you
the Ponte and how I'm gonna for that as
it's you I'm here and coming in a big
personage okay but instead bring her
into it look bring her into it and I use
that this not we're here and then
[Music]
you see not no contact and contact on
the back contact on the forward and now
the technique happens it does that
you're doing the other thing like you
see I'm opening you're trying to take it
but if we if we have that easy to be
pushes into me there's it takes don't
freak out
stick with the tactic you're in here
they send you down and then they wait
for you to come up listen that's not
what we do here okay so he goes we're in
here right and then you go down and then
he runs comes up and then I take badges
oh that's very much like I'm going to
hold him and then he reacts like he
pulls me back to see and then that is
martial strategy but it's not like he
knows do you understand
that's the same thing as would get you
capitalize on me yeah
so when you coming here I don't feel
like this comes up and if anyone takes
you down if you are like you know that
don't come back up during Santa's just
go attend you get a shove he goes this
Friday here right
I pulled he resisted and so then I came
in his mouth movement okay so he's here
he pulls me in on supposed to come in I
must be reactionary and over myself
often app so the same thing is you can
he goes like this he takes me down I'm
not supposed to go he takes me down
right
right let me here now he's getting up
boat you can't go down that's a little
different right here
that's capitalizing begin if I don't
take him down all the way you just this
year so in the key one we already had
that direction the center going forward
and it stays forward and if you get his
head to go down it's not going forward
it's going back and you should go do
something else
even on this part don't aim his head
down center forward with bringing his
head down
so you're here this isn't doing that
this is driving where the hydros
here you go check here I don't care
about them it's this to get what it
looks like like you you're over there
side of the Hat and then you check the
back it's this and doing what doing this
so your oversized and a half clothes off
the side the guy weighs a lot he's very
heavy and you're emphasizing the center
here okay go right generate a reaction
in the person and if we're reactive feed
so we do the opposite you put a whole
you pull I push you push I push you pull
that whole that's the onion microwave me
you're trying to do what I just said
trying to do the opposite if you pull my
user if you push I turn yeah so I don't
want to carry this reactionary through
drill through the whole say nappy into
my Hemi orange my Marshall strategy yes
you can do it it's very I use them all
the time in long okay but you keep up
mama you try another strategy which is
I'm not opposite you we're one thing
you're here I move you move okay
okay